reboots reimaginings the odd behind the
scenes spat actors can be replaced
between movies for any number of reasons
and sometimes it goes very very wrong in
the early 9s Michael Keaton handed over
the keys for Wayne Manor having
portrayed Bruce Wayne in 1989's Batman
and its 1992 sequel Batman Returns
reportedly Katon refused to reprise the
role in the third film after reading the
screenplay and in the years since has
pointed the blame for his departure
squarely at the writers Val Kilmer
clearly didn't share Keaton's misgivings
the tombstone star accepted the role as
is and went into the film knowing he'd
have to contend with a famous cast of
villains and a new director riddle me
this riddle me that who's afraid of the
big black Pat in the end Joel schacher
shouldered a lot of the blame for 1995's
Batman Forever though his leading man
didn't Escape criticism Kilmer's
performance was described as utterly
lethargic and God awful with a review
published by film 4 specifically calling
out Keaton's replacement as being simply
not up to the job many planned Superman
projects failed to come to fruition in
the years after 1987's resoundingly
terrible Superman 4 the Quest for Peace
nearly 20 years later the Man of Steel
returned to the big screen for 2006's
Superman Returns director Brian singer's
take on DC's prized property proved to
be a solid enough platform to take the
franchise forward though the vast budget
meant that the movie wasn't a financial
success that said Brandon Ralph's turn
as the man of steel Drew praise from
many with Newsweek in particular gushing
over Ralph for the way in which the
newcomer effortlessly lays claim to the
iconic role the outlet even favorably
compared him to Christopher Reed
although DC intended to produce a sequel
to Superman Returns every year that
passed made it less likely to happen
despite Ralph making it quite clear that
he wanted to to Dawn the red cape again
the studio opted to reboot the franchise
with Man of Steel a Zack Snyder reboot
fronted by Henry Cav trouble is Snider's
film took the aspect of Superman Returns
that people didn't like the morose
humorless tone and Amplified it Cav's
downbeat portrayal of the titular Hero
has been criticized for being too
brooding and too dark leading to a
Superman film that's practically devoid
of Joy today Back to the Future stands
as a Timeless classic that can continues
to Delight audiences of all ages crisen
Glover played the role of Marty's father
George in arguably his most iconic role
from cowardly creep to confident Ladies
Man George undergos the most significant
transformation in the trilogy both on
and off camera in fact some might not
even realize that Glover didn't return
for Back to the Future Part Two in which
he was replaced by Jeffrey Weissman
wearing Glover inspired Prosthetics
despite having fully recast Jennifer
Parker for the sequels the filmmakers
opted to hide their new George McFly via
Prosthetics and clever filmmaking
techniques that made it nearly
impossible to spot the fake originally
co-writer and co-producer Bob Gail
claimed the Glover quit due to a pay
dispute but Glover himself has denied
this on a number of occasions instead he
says he was removed from the burgeoning
franchise after voicing his distaste for
the ending of the original movie which
he believed implied that the McFly's
happiness was dependent on material
wealth wo this is heavy for part two the
filmmakers spliced footage of Glover's
performance from the first film added
new material with Wiseman and killed off
George McFly in the alternate 1985 to
keep audiences from discovering the
truth it worked well enough but upon
rewatch it's clear how hard director
Robert zamus tried to hide the fact that
Glover wasn't involved perhaps
unsurprisingly Glover was less than
thrilled about his face being used
without his permission years later he
told the AV club they thought that was
funny they knew that they could
basically torment me either financially
or by what ultimately was an illegal
thing to do I'm sure they laughed and
joked about it liveaction Bruce Waynes
tend to find a new love interest in each
installment of the Batman franchise from
Kim Basinger's Vicky Veil to Nicole
Kidman's Dr Chase Meridian The Dark
Knight certainly gets around but for
Christopher Nolan's Visionary take on
the character's Origins a new bat love
was born in 2005's Batman Begins Katy h
hes played Bruce Wayne's childhood
friend turned love interest Rachel Daws
at the end of the film Rachel tells
Bruce that they can only be together
when Gotham City no longer needs Batman
setting up an intriguing Arc for the two
characters however Holmes quit Nolan's
Batman sequel in favor of the Buddy
comedy mad money she was replaced by
Maggie Gyllenhaal in the Dark Knight no
doubt Gyllenhaal delivers an excellent
performance and she certainly fits the
tone of the sequel but it's hard to
believe that this Rachel is the same
character as home
not only is gyllen Hall's Rachel more
Cavalier than her begins counterpart but
she doesn't seem as personally invested
in Bruce as she did before sure some of
that is due to plot reasons namely her
romance with Harvey Dent but it also may
be that jillen Hall simply didn't have
the same chemistry with Christian Bale
as her predecessor Hugo weaving's
absence was sorely felt in The Matrix
resurrections that's not to say that
Jonathan Gruff who replaced weaving as
the villainous program known as Smith is
not a talented actor sadly he had huge
shoes to fill even in reloaded and
revolutions weaving shines brightest
among the cast while Ian Bliss tackles
an inspired impersonation when the
character takes over a human host but
the fourth time was not the CH Mr
Anderson it can't be considering
weaving's iconic turn as Smith a new
version of the character needed to feel
either identical or significantly
different from the original in order to
work unfortunately gr's portrayal and
Resurrection is neither deemed an
algorithm of unoriginality by the
guardian the fourth Matrix movie failed
to recapture what made the relationship
between Neo and Smith so special and
that's due at least in part to weaving's
absence there was plenty of controversy
surrounding the making of the animated
movie scoop a reboot feature meant to
Kickstart a new theatrical Scooby-Doo
franchise between unceremoniously
cancelled sequels and the film's failed
attempt to launch a Cinematic Universe
the biggest problem with scoo was its
casting despite retaining Frank Welker
as the iconic voice of Scooby-Doo the
rest of the Mystery Inc gang was
scrapped for this installment including
Matthew Lillard's Shaggy Rogers Lillard
gained widespread Acclaim when he played
Shaggy in the two live-action Scooby-Doo
movies in the early 2000s he went on to
take over vocal duties from Casey kasm
for subsequent animated movies and
Television Productions to this day
Lillard still plays Shaggy as Faithfully
as ever but he missed out on the 2020
return to the big screen after the fil
film's cast was revealed Lillard took to
X formerly known as Twitter to write
well this sucks what a crappy way to
find out thanks Hollywood of course
Lillard wasn't the only one replaced in
the new movie nor was he the only one
disappointed by the news but given his
many years playing Shaggy it was tough
news nonetheless and it didn't help that
will Forte's Shaggy just sounded like a
higher pitched Will Forte rather than
Shaggy thankfully Lillard has since
resumed voicing Shaggy in all other
Scooby-Doo projects some movies should
never be remade we don't need another
Citizen Kane Casablanca or vertigo for
example and we certainly didn't need
another psycho what's worse is that
director Gus vanan Sant chose to remake
the film nearly shot for shot even
copying some of Alfred Hitchcock's
signature camera movements it's
unsettling to be sure but maybe that was
the point in any case Anthony Perkins
who gave a straightup iconic performance
in the 1960 original can't be easily
overshadowed so when Vince Von was cast
as Norman baits in the remake folks were
understandably skeptical given Von's
usual filmography his casting in Psycho
made for something of a strange Choice
as Roger eert wrote he isn't odd enough
Norman's early dialogue often ends in a
nervous laugh Bon's laugh doesn't seem
involuntary when all is said and done
Von's Norman is still a psycho but he's
a strange and unlayered one at Best and
not nearly as frightening as Perkins
original like the rest of anan's psycho
remake Von's performance proves the
Folly and trying to reinvent the wheel
can you believe that there have been no
fewer than six Home Alone movies
obviously the first two directed by
Chris Columbus and starring mcau culan
are the best by far over the years home
alone and lost in New York have become
Christmas classics while the other less
inventive sequels simply rode the
franchise's coattails you guys give up
or you're thirsty for more but though
most of the sequels feature a new
protagonist in the place of young Kevin
the directed video Home Alone 4 opted to
resurrect the original League albeit
without Culkin's involvement the fourth
film takes place seemingly a few years
after lost in New York with the
mallister family in complete disarray
and not just because they've all been
recast too here Kevin is played by Mike
Weinberg who isn't nearly as charismatic
or lovable as culen though he does look
younger in fact if the character's name
had been changed you'd have no clue that
this was supposed to be the same kid no
doubt culan was looked over because Home
Alone 4 was released 12 years after the
original but that's no excuse as the
radio Times review says you have to
wonder why they bothered Not only was
Home Alone Ford destined to be a train
wreck after a poor third installment but
trying to capitalize on the mallister
family without utilizing any returning
faces turned out to be nothing short of
a disaster let's chalk it all up to real
Kevin's bad dream Billy D Williams
played a pre- disfigured version of
Harvey Dent in Tim Burton's 1989 Batman
Dent's appearance was no doubt meant to
tease the characters on-screen future as
Twoface attorney finally made in Batman
Forever but in that film it wasn't
Williams facing off against The Dark
Knight but Tommy Lee Jones we all know
that Val Kilmer replaced Michael Keaton
as Batman but many forget that Williams
dent and Jones's Twoface are meant to be
one and the same very few people are
both a summer and a winter
but you pull it off
nicely of course there's a clear
difference between the two ation of the
character appearance aside William stent
is a charismatic leader hoping to use
his status to change the hearts and
minds of Voters on the contrary Jones's
two face isn't much more than a maniacal
sidekick to Jim car's over-the-top
Riddler which only makes Batman Forever
feel all the more outlandish Roger eert
may have once deemed forever better than
Batman Returns but the movie strange
tone and misuse of Tommy Lee Jones make
it a controversial bat flick to this day
in 2021 DC Comics published a comic
continuation to Batman and Batman
Returns that follows the Michael Keaton
incarnation of The Dark Knight written
by Batman screenwriter Sam ham the
series revives Williams version of
Harvey Dent and Chronicles the
character's troubl turn into twoof faace
thus establishing the events of forever
as an alternate timeline Tom Cruz
brought the vampire leat de Leonor to
life in the film adaptation of an Rice's
novel Interview with a Vampire Cruz's
memorable performance opposite Brad Pitt
and a young Kirsten dun is certainly a
highlight of the film but did you know
there was a sequel Cruz didn't reprise
his vampiric role however which is
probably why many people haven't heard
of it instead Stuart Townsen took over
for 2002's queen of the dam also based
on an an rice novel Queen of the Damned
was a complete and utter failure not
only did the movie tank at the box
office but rice wasn't particularly
thrilled with it either and no other
movies based on the vampire Chronicles
have been released since while Townsend
may have better resembled the character
from the novel in terms of physicality
he didn't have the same sort of Gravitas
that Cruz brought to the role film
threats review of the movie read Tom
Cruz had the good sense to stay away
from reprising his role of leat in this
film and audiences should demand this
film be buried never to see the light of
day again Hugo weaving wasn't the only
actor replaced in the Matrix
resurrections Lawrence Fishburn played
Morpheus in all three installments of
the original trilogy as well as the Inc
Cannon Matrix online video game which
chronicled the character's death because
of his work in The Matrix Fishburn has
become a Hollywood staple he even
reunited with former co-star Kean Reeves
on multiple occasions in the John Wick
series at last rather than keep Morpheus
in the grave The Matrix resurrections
resurrects the character now played by
Yaya Abdul matin
II at
last H wasn't too sure about the call
back but you know it's just hard to
resist much like agent Smith's recasting
Abdul matin makes a valiant attempt to
bring Morpheus back to life this
Morpheus isn't the original but rather a
program meant to help Neo achieve his
Destiny which makes this red pill a
little easier to swallow nevertheless
the lack of Fishburn no doubt
contributed to the critical and
Commercial failures of resurrections
every Matrix sequel has proved that it's
nearly impossible to recapture what made
the original great but at least the
first two follow-ups retained most of
their original casts compared to the
first two Cameron films it's
understandable why most folks dislike
Terminator 3 rise of the Machines the
movie tries a bit too hard with the
jokes and aside from John Connor's
compelling character Arc it doesn't
really break any new ground still one of
the strongest aspects of T3 is the
budding romance between John and a young
Kate Brewster who learns all about
Skynet Terminators and Judgment Day just
a day or so before it occurs the end of
the
world it's today 3 hour hours from now 2
hours and 53 minutes so when the movie
ends and John and Kate are trapped
underground we're left to wonder what's
next half a decade later Terminator
Salvation replaced Nick stalls John
Connor with Christian Bale and CLA D's
Kate Brewster with Bryce Dallas Howard
compared to D's Howard's portrayal is
fairly one note though to be fair she
hasn't given half as much to do as her
predecessor salvation barely even
centers around John Connor let alone
Kate so it's no surprise that Howard had
little to work with in a 2009 interview
with Cinema Blend the actor shared the
way that my character best serviced the
film was being kind of an emotional
sounding board for John Connor while the
Mortal Kombat video games and animated
movies have done particularly well over
the years translating such a stylized
world into live action can prove
difficult so when director Paul WS
Anderson released his vision in 1995
fans were surprisingly happy with the
results the film starred Christopher
Lambert as raid along with an ensemble
cast that did a decent job at bringing
these characters to life unfortunately
he didn't return in the sequel years
later Lambert revealed that he didn't
like the script for Mortal Kombat
Annihilation and who can blame him
taking over his Raiden was James rear
who wasn't exactly notable in the role
although IGN later admitted that Remar
played the part well theet couldn't get
past how bad the rest of the movie was
saying hilariously awful mat shots cheap
costumes obvious sets and some of the
worst CG ever put in a mainstream
release feel nearly every scene of this
movie No Doubt Mortal Kombat
Annihilation is a total train wreck and
even though James rear did his best to
make his part memorable it only reminds
us of how terrible the rest of the movie
is Halloween Town was one of the most
beloved Disney Channel features to hit
TV screens in fact it was so popular
with ' 90s kids that two sequels were
made in the Years following but then a
darker installment came following Marney
pip her into her college Years only this
time she wasn't played by The Lovable
Kimberly J Brown as Sarah Paxton instead
stepped into the role return to
Halloween Town was kind of a mess though
the majority of the original cast
returned Paxton was the odd one out
playing an older Marney to whom viewers
didn't recognize or relate strangely
some House of Mouse witchcraft must have
been a foot since there are two
conflicting accounts of why Brown was
recast in the first place in 2010 Brown
told October 31st .org I wanted to do
the fourth one and was fully available
for the shoot Disney decided not to use
me for the fourth one I don't know why I
was definitely disappointed not to do it
but producer Sherry singer had a
different story in 2017 she told E
online it was not something we wanted to
do we couldn't make the deal work that
was why and we didn't want to not do it
sometimes movies reference the fact that
a certain actor has been recast hey
buddy didn't expect to see you here look
it's me I'm here deal with it let's move
on occasionally a movie even takes pains
to explain the change in actor it could
have been a dream plastic surgery or
some other strange offscreen development
and every now and again they just
straight to admit they couldn't afford
the real deal that was the case with
George of the Jungle 2o in the first
movie George was played by the ever
talented Brendan Fraser but for Disney's
direct video sequel Christopher
showerman took over the titular role and
the filmmakers weren't shy about
admitting it me new George Studio too
cheap to pay Brenan Fraser of course
George isn't the only character recast
in the sequel Julie Ben replaced Leslie
man as Ursula stanh hope as well
strangely Thomas Hayden Church reprised
his role as Lyall Vander from the first
film even though his presence couldn't
save this one if the directive video
budget Didn't Give It Away George of the
Jungle 2 is full of bad CGI a retread of
the film's first plot and of course
absolutely no Brendan Fraser in sight in
a review from DVD verdict showerman was
described as a non-entity who only
serves as an imitation of Brendan
Fraser's interpretation of George nobody
took over Kiana Reeves role as officer
Jack traven from the 9s action classic
speed but the Lost Boys Legend Jason
Patrick replaced him as the male lead
for its sequel Speed 2 cruise control
Reeves instead chose to pursue other
action roles which eventually led to the
likes of Constantine and John but with
Reeves out for the count and Patrick
stepping in as officer Alex Shaw speed
two could only end in a wreck and wreck
it did many cited Patrick's performance
in the screenplay as some of the film's
biggest issues Time magazine's review
said he's stalwart and athletic but
fundamentally uninteresting others
including original Speed Star Sandra
Bullock wished they could forget about
cruise control entirely interestingly
Reeves is apparently open to returning
as Jack traven one day while promoting
joh Wick chapter 4 Reeves told Access
Hollywood that a great story and a great
script would convince him to come back
for Speed 3 after the commercial success
of the 1994 liveaction adaptation of The
Flintstones a sequel was certainly on
the cards at Universal Pictures so when
another liveaction Flintstones titled
The Flintstones in Viva Rock Vegas
showed up in theaters 6 years later
nobody was particularly surprised the
first film had been panned by critics
but the second well that was was a real
disaster for starters Viva Rock Vegas is
a prequel rather than a sequel and the
movie recasts its comedic leads the
original movie starred John Goodman as
Fred Rick Moranis as Barney Elizabeth
Perkins is Wilma and Rosie O'Donnell as
Betty Viva Rock Vegas starred Mark Addie
as Fred Steven Baldwin as Barney Kristen
Johnson as Wilma and Jane Kowski as
Betty to say that any of these actors
are untalented that on their own would
be untrue but that doesn't mean they
were the right folks for the job while
The Flintstones was no Masterpiece
itself the lack of comedic timing
uninspired jokes and lackluster cast of
the sequel hardly set it up for success
as Roger eert wrote minute by weary
minute the movie wins its weary way
toward its joyless conclusion no wonder
a third liveaction Flintstones is never
materialized one of the few things that
Terminator Genesis did well was recreate
the opening SE quence from the original
James Cameron movie from the deaged
Arnold Schwarzenegger to the rebuilt
sets the 1984 sequence is an Exquisite
duplication that totally holds up to the
original of course Genesis diverges from
there with the biggest change being the
lack of 80s action icon Michael Bean
come with me if you want to live while
Amelia Clark sort of resembles Linda
Hamilton's Sarah Connor ji Courtney
looks absolutely nothing like the Kyle
ree were used to to its credit 2009's
Terminator s salvation featured a
younger version of the character one
that still embodied the Kyle we all know
and
love come with me if you want to live
but Courtney who lacks a certain kind of
Charisma doesn't translate well at all
unfortunately Genesis was already a mess
and a half to begin with and a planned
series of movies was quickly cancelled
after the movie faced an increasingly
negative reception unsurprisingly Kyle
ree hasn't appeared in a Terminator
movie since in the original X-Men films
team leader Scott Summers was played by
James maren though he was written a bit
too much like a jealous boyfriend at
times maren did a decent job bringing
this Marvel hero to life especially when
it came to his Dynamic with Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine but by the time
X-Men the Last Stand came around the
actor had decided to star in Superman
Returns forcing Cyclops untimely demise
thankfully once Wolverine fixed the
timeline and Xmen Days of Future Past
Scott was resurrected giving us a New
Hope for his future and then he was was
recast X-Men apocalypse the direct
sequel to first class and Days of Future
Past introduced audiences to a younger
Scott Summers one who has yet to grow
into the hero embodied by Marsden in the
original trilogy played by Tai Sheridan
Cyclops is no longer the field leader of
the X-Men nor does he have much agency
in a movie that mostly centers on Xavier
Magneto and Mystique despite Sheridan's
struggle to bring cyclops to life in
Apocalypse and its sequel dark Phoenix
James Marsden supported his successor
citing the young actor's role in mud as
a particular accomplishment in 2015 he
told HitFix I think he's a wonderfully
talented actor I think he's a perfect
fit few actors perfectly embody their
comic book counterparts quite like the
cast of Marvel Cinematic universes phase
one Robert Downey Jr as Iron Man Chris
Evans as Captain America and Samuel L
Jackson as Nick Fury were certainly
inspired as was Edward Norton as Bruce
Banner AKA The Incredible Hulk appearing
as as the angry Green Giant in 2008's
The Incredible Hulk Norton's portrayal
of the runaway scientist felt ripped
from the original Marvel Comics
themselves Not only was Norton able to
deafly balance Bruce's struggles with
mental health and his desire for
impossible intimacy but his Hulk was
also Fierce powerful and best embodied
the character's rage but then Norton
exited the MCU never to return 2014 he
told The Hollywood Reporter my feeling
was that I experimented and experienced
what I wanted too I really really
enjoyed it and yet I looked at the
balance of time and life that one spends
not only making those sorts of films but
then especially putting them out and the
obligations that rightly come with that
so for 2012's Grand team up featured the
Avengers Marvel recast Mark Ruffalo as
Bruce
Banner that's my secret
cat I'm always angry Ruffalo has played
the reluctant hero ever since but
unfortunately his more comedic take on
the character feels too far removed from
Norton's intricately complex dive into
Bruce Banner's psyche in this case at
least it seems like the MCU opted for
style over
substance